write a huge draw on the strip of course
are the world famous shows
and one of the most popular one returns
to the stage tonight
absinthe is a risque variety show at
caesar's palace
they've made several changes to increase
audience safety and safety in general
so capacity will be limited there's also
a new ac system
to increase airflow there along with a
better filtration system
we spoke with ross mollison he's the
show's producer he says the cast cannot
wait to get back on stage
we're really excited about that because
we've got all these new creative ideas
we've come up with ways because
you may know that like our brand is
really
about intimacy we really get out amidst
the audience
and and have some fun and obviously we
can't do a lot of that stuff
now so we've had to really be creative
to come up with ways
that make that sense of fun still happen
and i think people are going to really
love it i think we've come up with some
really exciting ideas
i'm sure they will he also told us
bringing back shows is the key
to bringing back las vegas we need all
the shows back open
we need all the resorts open nobody
comes to vegas just to stay at caesar's
palace they
they want to walk up and down the strip
they might go to dinner at bellagio
you know or the cosmopolitan or the
venetian you know so that that whole
range of activity
has to come back to town he said his
team
has written a 52-page safety handbook
that will be shared with his other shows
over at the cosmopolitan
and the venetian so absent coming back
tonight some good news yeah